the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or to view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
okay so so far we've learned how to do
double integrals in terms of XY
coordinates also how to switch to polar
coordinates but marginally there's a lot
of different changes of variables that
you might want to do okay so today we're
going to see how to change variables if
you want how to do substitutions in
double integrals
okay so let me start with a simple
example let's say that we want to find
the area of an ellipse with semi-axes a
and B okay so that means you know an
ellipse is just like a squished circle
and so there's a and s B and the
equation of that ellipse is x over a
squared plus y over B squared equals 1
well that's the curve and the inside
region is where this is less than 1 okay
so it's just like a circle but where you
have way scaled x and y differently so
let's say we want to find the area of
that maybe you know what the area is but
let's do it as double integral
so are you know if you find that Aria is
too easy you can integrate any function
of other ellipse if you prefer but let's
do it just with area so we know that we
want to integrate just the area element
let's say DX dy over a region inside the
ellipse that's x over a squared plus y
over b squared less than 1 now we can
try to set this up in terms of x and
y-coordinates you know set up the bounds
by solving for first for x as a function
of y if we do it this order and well do
the usual stuff that doesn't look very
pleasant and it's certainly not the best
way to do it if this were a circle we
would switch to polar coordinates well
we can't quite do that yet but you know
an ellipse is just a squished circle so
maybe we want to actually first rescale
x and y by a and B to reduce to the case
of a circle so to do that what we'd like
to do is set X over a vu and Y over B be
V so we'd have two new variables U and V
and we'll try to redo our integral in
terms of U and V so how do we do the
substitution so in terms of U and V the
condition the region that we are
integrating on will become u square plus
v square less than 1 which is arguably
nicer than the ellipse that's what's why
we're doing it but we need to know what
to do with DX and dy well here the
answer is pretty easy because we just
change x and y separately we do two
independent substitutions okay so if we
set you know if we set u equals x over a
that means V U is 1 over a DX and here
DV is 1 over B dy so
we it's very tempting to write and here
we actually we can write in this
particular case that dudv is one of our
a/b dxdy okay so let me rewrite it
okay so I get dudv equals one over a B
DX dy or equivalently DX dy is a B times
D u DV okay so in my double integral I'm
going to write a B D u DV okay so now my
double integral becomes well the double
integral of a constant in terms of U and
V so I can take the constant out I will
get a B times double integral of U
square plus B square less than one of
dudv and that is an integral that we
know how to do well because it's the
area it was the area of a unit circle so
we can just say oh this is a B times the
area of a unit disk which we know to be
PI or if somehow you had some function
to integrate then you could have
switched to polar coordinates you know
setting u equals R cos theta v equals R
sine theta and then doing it in polar
coordinates okay so here the
substitution worked pretty easily the
question is you know if we do a change
of variables where the relation between
x and y and U and V is more complicated
what can we do can we still do this or
do we have to be more careful and
actually we have to be more careful so
that's what we're going to see next but
any question about this first
No okay
okay so see the general problem when we
try to do this is to figure out what is
the scale factor what's the relation
between DX dy and the UDV so we need to
find the scaling factor so we need to
find DX dy is SD u DD so let's do
another example that's still pretty easy
but a little bit less easy okay so let's
say that for some reason we want to set
we want to do the change of variables u
equals 3x minus 2y and V equals x plus y
why would we want to do that well that
might be to simplify the integrand
because we're integrating a function
that happens to be actually involving
these guys other than x and y or it
might be to simplify the bounds because
maybe we're integrating over a region
whose equation in X Y coordinates is
very hard to write down but it becomes
much easier in terms of U and V and then
you know the bounds will be much easier
to set up with U and V anyway so you
know whatever the reason might be
typically it would be to simplify the
integrand over bounds
well how do we convert the X dy to the U
DV so we want to understand what's the
relation between let's call da the area
element in XY coordinates so da is DX dy
may be dy DX depending on the other and
the area element in UV coordinates let
me call that da Prime just you know to
make it look different so that would
just be the U DV or DVD you depending on
which order I will want to set it up in
so to find this relation it's probably
best to draw a picture to see what
happens
you know let's consider a small piece of
the XY plane with area Delta a
corresponding to just you know a box
with sides Delta Y and Delta X okay and
let's try to figure out what it will
look like in terms of U and V and then
we'll say well when we integrate we're
really summing the value of a function
of a lot of small boxes times they are
here but the problem is that the area of
the box in here is not the same as the
area of a box in UV coordinates you know
there may be it will look like actually
you know if you see that these are
linear changes of variables you know
that a rectangle will become a
parallelogram after the change of
variables so the area of a parallelogram
Delta a prime well we have to figure out
how they're related so that we can
decide what conversion factor what's the
exchange rate between these two
currencies for RL any questions at this
point note still with me mostly I see a
lot of tired faces yes
why is Delta a prime a parallelogram
that's a very good question well see
here if I look at this side of the right
angle so this vertical side means I'm
going to increase Y keeping X the same
if I look at the formulas for u and V
they're linear formulas in terms of x
and y so if I just increase Y see that U
is going to decrease at a rate of 2 V is
going to increase at a rate of 1 at
constant rates and it doesn't matter
whether I was looking at this side or
that side so basically straight lines
become straight lines and you know if
they're parallel they stay parallel so
if you just look at what the
transformation from XY to UV does it
does this kind of thing actually
this transformation here you can express
by your matrix and remember we've seen
what matrices do to pictures we just you
know take straight lines to straight
lines they keep the notion of being
parallel but of course the mess up
lengths and goals and all that ok so
let's see so let's try to figure out
what is the area of this guy well in
fact what I've been saying about you
know this transformation being linear
and transforming all of the vertical
lines in the same way all the horizontal
lines in the same way tells me also I
should have a constant scaling factor
right because how much I've scaled my
rectangle doesn't matter doesn't depend
on where my rectangle is if I move my
rectangle to somewhere else I have a
rectangle the same size same shape it
will become a parallelogram of the same
size same shape somewhere else so in
fact I can just take the simplest
rectangle I can think of and see how
it's our changes and if you don't
believe me then you know try with any
other rectangle you will see it works
exactly the same way okay so I claim
that the area scaling factor
here in this case doesn't depend on the
choice of the right angle and I should
say that because we are actually doing
linear change of variables so you know
somehow the exchange rate between UV and
XY is going to be the same everywhere so
let's try to see what happens to the
simplest right angle I can think of
namely just the unit square and you know
if you don't trust me then you know
while I'm doing this one do it with a
different rectangle do the same
calculation and see that you will get
the same conversion ratio so let's say
that I take a unit square so some a it
has size that goes from 0 to 1 both in x
and y directions ok and let's try to
figure out what it looks like on the
other side so here the area is 1 let's
try to draw it in terms of U and D
coordinates okay so here we have x
equals 0 y equals 0 well that tells us U
and V are going to be 0 next let's look
at this corner well in XY coordinates
this is 1 0 if you plug x equals 1 y
equals 0 you get u equals 3 V equals 1
so that goes somewhere here
and so this edge of the square will
become this line here next let's look at
that point so that point here was 0 1 if
I plug x equals 0 y equals 1 I will get
negative 2 and 1 so this edge goes here
then if you put x equals 1 y equals 1
you will get u equals 1 v equals 2 so I
want one too and these edges will go to
these edges here and you see it does
look like a parallelogram ok so now
what's the area of this parallelogram
well we can get that by taking the
determinant of these two vectors so one
of them is 3 1 and the other 1 is minus
2 1 that will be 3 plus 2 that's 5 this
parallelogram is apparently 5 times the
size of the square here it looks like
it's less because I've somehow changed
my scale I mean my unit length is
smaller here than here so but it should
be a lot bigger than that ok and if you
do the same calculations not with you
know 0 & 1 but with X and X plus Delta X
and so on you will still find that the
area has been multiplied by 5 so that
tells us
actually for any of a rectangle area is
also multiplied by five so that tells us
that da Prime the area element in UV
coordinates is worth five times more
that than the area element in XY
coordinates so that means the UDV is
worth five times DX dy what's so funny
what
oh okay all right tango okay is it okay
now a dice but did I've misspelled other
words no okay it's really hard to see
when you're that close up it's much
easier from a distance
okay so yeah so we've said our
transformation multiplies Ras by 5 and
so dudv is 5 times DX dy so if I'm
integrating some function DX dy then
when I switch to UV coordinates I will
have to replace that by 1/5 dudv okay
and of course I would also you know here
my function would probably involve X&Y I
will replace them by using these and the
bounds well the shape of my region in
the XY coordinates I will have to switch
to some shape in the UV coordinate and
that's also something that might be easy
or might be tricky depending on what
region we're looking at so you usually
will do changes of variables to actually
simplify the region you know so that it
becomes easier to set up the bounds so
anyway so this is kind of an
illustration of a general case and why
is that well here it looks very easy you
know we're just using linear formulas
and somehow the relation between DX dy
and EU DV is the same everywhere if you
take actually more complicated changes
of variables that's not true because
usually you will expect that you know
that some places where very scaling is
maybe enlarging things and some of the
places where things are shrunk so
certainly the exchange rate between dudv
and dxdy will fluctuate from point to
point
you know it's same as if you are trying
to change dollars to euros it depends on
where you do it you will get a better
rate or worse one so you know we have to
of course we'll get a formula where
actually this scaling factor will depend
on x and y are on U and V but if you fix
a point then we have linear
approximation and linear approximation
tells us oh we can do as if our function
is just a linear function of x and y so
then we can do it the same way we did
here okay so let's let's try to think
about that so in the general case well
that means you know we'll replace X and
y by new coordinates U and V and U and V
will be some functions of x and y so
well we'll have an approximation formula
which tells us that the change in U if I
change X on Y a little bit will be
hopefully u sub x times change in X plus
u sub y times change in Y and the change
in V will be hopefully V sub X Delta X
plus V sub y Delta Y so the other way to
say it if you want in matrix form is
Delta u Delta V is so approximately
equal to u sub X u sub Y V sub X V sub y
times
Delta X and Delta Y okay so if we look
at that what it tells us in fact is that
if we take a small rectangle in XY
coordinates so that means we have a
certain point XY and then we have a
certain width this is going to be too
small either
well so I have my width Delta X I have
my height Delta Y this is going to
correspond to a small UV parallelogram
and you know what the shape and the size
of that parallelogram are depend on the
partial derivatives of U and V so in
particular they depend on at which point
where but still at a given point it's a
bit like that and so if we do the same
argument as before what we'll see is
that the scaling factor is actually the
determinant of this transformation so
that's one thing that maybe we did not
emphasize enough when we did matrices at
the beginning of the semester but when
you have a linear transformation between
variables the determinant of that
transformation represents how it scales
areas okay so one way to think about it
is just you know to try and see what
happens you know take take this side
this side in XY coordinates corresponds
to Delta X and zero and now if you take
the image of that if you see what
happens to Delta U and Delta V that will
be basically use of X Delta X and V sub
X Delta X there is no Delta Y for the
other side ok so maybe I should do it
actually so you know if we move in the
XY coordinates by Delta X and 0 then
Delta U and Delta V will be u sub X be
approximately u sub X Delta X and V sub
X Delta X
and in the other hand if you move in the
other direction along the other side of
your rectangle zero and Delta Y then the
change in U and the change in V will
correspond to
well how does you change that's U sub y
Delta Y and B changes by V sub y Delta Y
and so now if you take the determinant
of these two vectors okay so these are
the sides of your parallelogram up here
and if you take this side to get the
area of a parallelogram you will need to
take the determinant and the determinant
will be the determinant of this matrix
times Delta x times Delta Y so the area
in UV coordinates will be the
determinant of the matrix times Delta X
Delta Y and so what I'm trying to say is
that when you have a general change of
variables the UDV versus DX dy is given
by the determinant of this matrix of
partial derivatives it doesn't matter in
which order you write it I mean you can
put you know in holes or in columns if
you transpose a matrix that doesn't
change the determinant it's just you
know any sensible matrix that you can
write will have the correct determinant
okay so what we need to know is the
following thing so we define something
called the Jacobian of a change of
variables and use a little J or maybe a
more useful notation is partial of UV
over partial of XY that's a very strange
notation I mean that doesn't mean that
virtually taking the partial derivative
of anything okay it's just a notation to
remind us that this has to do with your
ratio between the U DV and DX dy and
it's made using it's obtained using the
partial derivatives of U and V with
respect to X and y so it's the
determinant of a matrix U sub X u sub y
V sub X V sub y now the matrix that I
had up there okay and what we need to
know is that the U DV is equal to the
absolute value of j DX dy now if you
prefer to see it in the easier to
remember version its absolute value of D
of U V over partial x y DX dy okay so
this is just what you need to remember
and it says that the area in UV
coordinates is worth well the ratio to
the area in the XY coordinates is given
by this Jacobian determinant except one
small thing it's given by actually the
absolute value of this guy okay so
what's going on here what's going on
here is when we are saying the
determinant of the transformation tells
us how the area is multiplied there's a
small catch remember determinants are
equal to areas up to sign some times the
determinant is negative because of
reversing the orientation of things but
the area is still the same area is
always positive
so the area elements are actually
related by the absolute value of this
guy okay so if you find you know minus
10 as your answer then dudv is still 10
times DX dy okay
so yeah I mean I didn't put it all
together because then you would have two
sets of vertical bars see I mean this is
a vertical bar for absolute value this
is a vertical bar for determinants they
are not the same that's the one thing to
remember okay any questions about this
nope okay
so actually let's do a first example of
that let's check what we had for polar
coordinates you know last time I told
you well if we have DX dy we should
switch it to our dr d-theta and we had
some argument for that by looking at the
area of a small piece of you know a
small circular sector but you know let's
check again using this new method so in
polar coordinates I'm setting x equals R
cosine theta y equals R sine theta so
the Jacobian for this change of
variables so let's say I'm trying to
find the partial derivatives of X Y with
respect to R theta well what is K let me
actually write them here again just for
you and so what does that become partial
x over partial R is just cosine theta
partial x over partial theta is negative
R sine theta sorry I guess I'm going to
run out of space here let me do it
underneath so we said X sub R is cosine
theta X sub theta is negative R sine
theta Y sub R is sine Y sub theta is R
cosine and now if we compute this
determinant
we'll get our cosine squared theta plus
R sine square theta and that simplifies
to our so DX dy is will absolute value
of our dr d-theta but remember that R is
always positive so it's Rd Rd theta
okay so that's another way to justify
how we did double integrals in polar
coordinates okay any questions on that
well yeah okay yeah so this one seems to
be switching well it depends what you do
see so okay actually here's an important
thing that I didn't quite say so I said
you know we're going to switch from XY
to UV we can also switch from UV to XY
and you know this conversion ratio the
Jacobian works both ways once you have
found you know the ratio between dudv
and dxdy then it works one way or it
works the other way I mean here of
course we get the answer in terms of R
so this would let us you know switch
from XY to R theta but we could also
switch from our theta 2xy just we would
write DRD theta equals 1 over r dxdy and
then we'd have of course to replace R by
its formula in XY coordinates usually we
don't do that usually we actually start
with XY and switch to polar orbit so in
general you know when you have this
formula relating the U DV with DX dy
you can use it both ways either to
switch from the U DV to DX dy or the
other way around and the thing that I'm
not telling you but now I should
probably tell you is you know I could
define two
jacobians because if I serve 4xy in
terms of UV instead of UV in terms of XY
then I can compute two different
jacobians I can compute partial UV over
partial XY or I can compute partial XY
order partial UV if I have the formulas
both ways well the good news is these
guys are the inverse of each other so
you know the two formulas that you might
get are consistent
okay so useful remark you know so say
that you can compute both these guys
well then actually the product will just
be one so you know very inverse of each
other so it doesn't matter which one you
compute you can compute whichever one is
the easiest to compute no matter of
which of which one of the two you need
and one way to see that is that in fact
you know we're looking at the
determinants of these matrices that tell
us the relation in variables so if one
of them tells you how Delta u Delta V
relate to Delta X Delta Y the other one
does the opposite thing it means that
the inverse matrices and the determinant
of the inverse matrix is the inverse of
the determinant so they're really
interchangeable I mean you can just you
know compute whichever one is easiest so
here if you wanted you know dr d-theta
in terms of DX dy it's easier to do this
and then movie our other where then to
first solve for our and theta as
functions of x and y and then do the
entire thing again but you can do it if
you want I mean it works
oh yeah we ever useful remark so I
mentioned it but let me emphasize again
so now the ratio between dudv and dxdy
it's not it's not a constant anymore
other where it used to be five but now
it's become CR or anything and in
general it would be a function that
depends on the variables so it's not tow
that you can just say oh I'll put a
constant times the UDV yes it would
still work the same you know you could
imagine drawing a picture where R and
theta are the Cartesian coordinates and
your picture would be completely messed
up it would be a very strange thing to
do to try to the whole you know and I'm
going to do it but don't take notes on
that you know you could try to draw a
picture like that and then you know a
circle would start looking like you know
what this could look like that and it
would be very counterintuitive but you
could do it and that would be equivalent
to what we did with the previous change
of variables so you know in this case
certainly you would never do a picture
like that but you could do it
okay
okay so now let's do a complete example
to see how things fit together you know
how we do everything so let's say that
we want to compute so I have to warn you
it's going to be a very silly example
it's an example where it's much easier
to compute things without the change of
variables but you know it's good
practice in the sense that we're going
to make it so complicated that if we can
do this one and we can do them all so
let's say that we want to compute this
and of course it's very easy to compute
it directly but let's say that for some
evil reason we want to do that by
changing variables to u equals x and V
equals XY okay that's a very strange
idea but let's do it anyway I mean
normally you know you would only do this
kind of substitution if either it
simplifies a lot of the function you're
integrating or it simplifies a lot of
the region on which you're integrating
and here never happens so but anyway so
the first thing we have to do here is
figure out what we are going to be
integrating okay so to do that first we
should figure out what DX dy will become
in terms of U and V so that's what we've
just seen using the Jacobian okay so the
first thing to do is find the area
element and for that we use the Jacobian
so well let's see the one that we can do
easily is partials of U and V with
respect to X and y I mean the other one
is not very hard because here you can
solve easily but the one that's given to
you is partial of U and V with respect
to X and y so partial u partial X is one
partial u partial Y is 0 partial V
partial X is y and partial V partial Y
is X okay so it's just X
so that means that the UDV is X DX dy
well it would be absolute value of X but
X is positive in our region so at least
we don't have to worry about that
okay so now that we have that we can try
to look at the integrand in terms of U
and V okay so we were integrating x
squared Y DX dy so let's switch it well
let's first switch the DX dy that
becomes 1 over X D u DV so that's
actually X Y the U DV and what is X Y in
terms of U and V well here at least we
have a little bit of luck you know X Y
is just V so that's V V u DV so in fact
what we'll be computing is a double
integral over some mysterious region of
V dudv okay now last but not least we'll
have to find what are the bounds for U
and V in the new integral so that we
know how to evaluate this
in fact where we could do it the UDV or
dvd we not know yet
Oh amazing 20 all the way down this time
okay so it could be DVD you if that's
easier so let's try to find the bounds
that's in this case that's we hardest
part okay so let me draw a picture in XY
coordinates and try to understand things
using that okay so x and y go from 0 to
1 the region that we want to integrate
over was just this square let's try to
figure out how u and V variant there so
let's say that we are going to do let's
say we're going to do a dudv ok so what
we want to understand is how u and v
vary in here what's going to happen so
the way we can think about it is we try
to figure out how we are slicing our
region okay so here we are integrating
first over u that means we start by
keeping u constant now by keeping V
constant as u changes ok so your changes
as V is constant what does it mean that
I'm keeping V constant well what is V V
is X Y so that means I keep X y equals
constant what does the curve X y equals
constant look like well it's just a
hyperbola okay y equals constant over X
so if I look at the various
values of V that they can take for each
value of V if I fix a value of V I will
be moving on one of these red curves
okay and you well you is the same thing
as X so that means you will increase you
know here maybe it will be point one and
it will increase to all the way to one
here okay so we are just traveling on
each of these slices now so the question
we must answer here is for a given value
of V what are the bounds for you so I'm
traveling on my curve V equals constant
and try to figure out when do I enter my
region whether or not when do I leave it
well I enter it when I go through this
side so the question is what's the value
of U here well we don't know that very
easily until we look at these formulas
so u equals x ok but we don't know what
X is at that point
well u equals x and V equals XY what do
we know here well we don't know X but we
know why certainly
ok so let's forget about trying to find
you and let's say for now we know y
equals 1 well if we set y equals 1 that
tells us that U and V above equal to X
so in terms of U and V the equation of
this in UV coordinates is U equals V ok
I mean the other way to do it is say
that you know you want y equals 1 you
want to know what is y in terms of U and
V well it's easy Y is V over u so let me
actually add an extra step in case
that's so we know that Y is V over u
equals 1 so that means u equals V is my
equation ok so when I'm here when I'm
entering my vision the value of U
at this point is just the u equals V
that's the hard part now we need to
figure out you know so we start at u
equals V u increases increases increases
where does it exit it exists when we are
here what's the value of u here one that
one is easier right this side here so
this side here is x equals one
that means u equals one so we start at u
equals one now we've done the inner
integral what about the outer so we have
to figure out what is the first and what
is the last value of v that will want to
consider well if you look at all these
hyperbolas XY equals constant what's the
smallest value of XY that we'll ever
want to look at in here zero okay that
actually was my yellow chalk
so this one here that's actually V
equals zero so we'll start at V equals
zero and what's the last type of weather
we want to look at what is the one
that's right there in the corner
so this one here and that's V equals one
so V goes from zero to one okay and now
we can compute this I mean it's not
particularly easier than that one but
it's not harder either how else could we
have gotten these bounds because that
was quite evil so I would like to
recommend that you give it a try this
way you know in case it works well just
try to picture what are the slices in
terms of U and V and how you travel on
them where you enter where you leave
staying in the XY picture if that
somehow doesn't work well another way is
to draw a picture in the UV coordinates
oops switch to a UV picture so what do I
mean by that well we had here a picture
in XY coordinates where we had our sides
and we're going to try to draw what it
looks like in terms of U and V so here
we say this is x equals 1 that becomes U
equals 1 so we'll draw u equals 1 this
side we say it is y equals 1 that
becomes u equals V that's what we've
done over there so u equals V now we
have the two other side to deal with but
let's look at this one first so that was
x equals 0 what happens when x equals 0
well both U and V are 0 so this side
actually gets squished in the change of
variables you know it's a bit it's a bit
strange but it's a bit the same thing as
you know when you switch to polar
coordinates at the origin is zero but
theta can be anything you know sometimes
not it's not always one point is one
point so anyway this is the
and then the last side y equals zero and
X varies just becomes V equals zero so
somehow in the change of variables this
square becomes this triangle and now if
we want to integrate the U DV it means
we're going to slice by V equals
constant so we're going to integrate
other slices like this and you see for
each value of V we go from u equals V to
u equals 1 and V goes from 0 to 1 ok so
you get the same bounds just by drawing
a different picture so it's up to you to
decide whether you prefer to you know
think on this picture or involve that
one instead it depends on which programs
you're doing